so the very first stars that formed
prior to to any galaxies were very
massive stars big stars 100 times the
mass of the Sun and they were made from
just hydrogen and helium so big stars
explode pretty fast after a few million
years only that's very short on Cosmic
time scales
and in their explosions they provided
the first heavier elements to the
universe because in that course All
Stars fuse lighter elements like
hydrogen helium into heavier ones
and then that goes all the way up to
iron and then all that material gets
ejected in these massive Supernova
explosions and that marked a really
really important
transition in the universe because after
that first explosion
it was no longer chemically pristine
and that's at the stage for everything
else to happen including us here talking
today so what do you mean by pristine so
there's a whole
complex soup of elements now as opposed
to just hydrogen helium and a little bit
of lithium yeah so after the big bang
just hydrogen and helium we don't really
need to talk too much about lithium
because the amount was so small
um and after these very first stars
formed and exploded they the heavier
elements like carbon oxygen magnesium
iron all of that stuff was was suddenly
present in the gas clouds uh tiny
amounts only very tiny amounts but and
that actually helped especially the
carbon and the oxygen to to make the gas
cool these atoms are more complicated
than hydrogen that's just a proton and
so it has cooling properties can send
out photons outside of the gas cloud so
the gas can cool and when you have gas
that that gets colder and colder you can
make smaller and smaller Stars so you
can fragment it and Clump it and turn it
into stars like like the sun and the
cool thing about that is that
when you have small stars like the sun
they have a really long lifetime so
those first low masters that formed back
then are still observable today
that is actually what I do I try to find
these early survivors
because they tell us
what the gas looked like back then they
have preserved that composition of these
early gas cloud the chemical
compositions
um until today so I don't need to look
very far uh into the universe to study
all the beginnings I can just chemically
analyze the oldest stars and it's like
unpacking everything that that happened
back then it's very exciting so to just
reiterate so in the very early days in
the first few million years
there's giant Stars that's mostly
hydrogen helium then they exploded in
these Supernova explosions and then they
made these clumps
non-pristine clumps yeah pretty much fun
so it took a few hundred million years
for the first stars to emerge and then
they exploded after a few million years
Kaboom and then it's like I always
consider the universe like a you know a
nice soup and then these first Supernova
explosions kind of provided the salt you
know just a little sprinkle of heavier
elements and that made it really tasty
it's just changed it completely right
and that changed the physics of the gas
so that meant that these these gas
clouds that were you know surrounding
the the the Forma first Stars they could
now cool down and Clump and form the
next generation of stars that now
included also little stars
and um as I just mentioned the small
stars have these really long lifetimes
the sun has a lifetime of 10 billion
years
any star that is even less massive will
have an even longer lifetime